you don't need to hurt him I need this
man looks at things what you need is
mechanical genius compared to me that
guy's a dope don't take him take me Alex
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Supergirl episode 3 episode 4
video thankfully a little extra time
this week so just talking about Maxwell
Lord and a couple of the big villains
that are coming on soon he was careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the the
big episode was reactron and Maxwell
Lord like we hadn't seen a lot from him
yet
for the most part reactron is actually
fairly authentic to the comic books they
actually the way they present him is
that he's been fighting Superman for a
long time then he finds out about
supergirls who is like okay I'm gonna
stick it to Superman by killing her and
Maxwell Lord kind of gets caught in the
crossfire or actually kind of throws
himself into the cross fires just taking
the show at face value it's a little
mysterious what his plans are but I mean
if you know about him in the comics you
have kind of an idea of where he's
headed Peter Facinelli was talking a
little bit about how he's different from
his classic comic book persona the way
he described Maxwell Lord in the comics
he's really talking about the old
version of Maxwell Lord not not so much
the more recent one like the one in
identity crisis that ends up killing the
Blue Beetle really they're like a couple
of big versions of Maxwell Lord so
depending on like when you read comics
or which run you're reading there's
slightly different versions there's the
classic version who helps bring the
Justice League together he's more of a
businessman type person then there's the
sinister checkmate telepath during
identity crisis that's when he shifts
into big bag villain mode that story
actually took a lot of what happened in
the classic Justice League stories and
twisted it in a really sinister way
Maxwell Lord reveals that he was playing
them all for fools the whole time then
he comes back for the blackest night art
although to be fair DC brought back
almost its entire catalogue that it had
killed off previously for that really
like the qualification for blackest
night was that you be a DC character at
some point regardless of your current
status living or dead they haven't
really done a whole lot with the
character since then like he just he's
not that big a character despite being a
relatively powerful person in the DC
Universe so what the TV show is doing is
it's taking that classic businessman
Maxwell Lord in applying some more
modern Lex Luthor ideas he's all about
humans pulling themselves up by their
own bootstraps not a big fan of
superheroes from outer space helping
them out but episode 4 which is airing
next week doesn't feature like the Freak
of the week so I think it's gonna double
down on Maxwell Lord the title of the
episode is
how does she do it so it just seems that
they're gonna be showcasing like a lot
of the comedy of Cara trying to be both
Supergirl and Cara during the day the
other really big thing we actually had
to talk about from last week is Hank
Henshaw I am more convinced than ever
that he's cyborg Superman now because it
was a scene where Cara's sister was
helping her out using the computer
inside there spec ops lab and all of a
sudden Hank Henshaw is walking down the
hallway and his eyes just light up like
he gets this internal notification that
someone's accessing their systems so
that makes me think that he has some
sort of cybernetic connection to their
computer systems which just screams
cyborg superman Martian Manhunter does
have telepathy so like he would be able
to just like sense something if he was
walking down the hallway if he was
specifically scanning for people's minds
but like I said in my previous Supergirl
videos just the way they're presenting
the character his personality
screams cyborg superman way more than
its screams martian manhunter after
watching season one of the flash i have
certain levels of expectation in terms
of villain reveals i don't think that
hank henshaw is gonna be a villain but I
do think that he'll be an antagonist
eventually Maxwell Lord is really the
villain you need to keep your eyes on
usually they say big villain reveals
like man in the Yellow suit reveals for
midseason finales so I'm expecting
something big for Maxwell Lord in the
mid-season finale if it wasn't clear his
company Lord Industries is kind of like
a green tech company think Elon Musk
Hyperloop trying to create something
that will help humanity and reduce
greenhouse emissions so he's trying to
do good things but just like you'd
expect from someone like Lex Luthor I
cannot wait to see him do something
crazy and over-the-top let me know in
the comments though like what do you
want to see from Maxwell Lords character
just think of him as the Harrison wells
of Supergirl billionaire genius that has
secret plans for Supergirl that he has
not revealed yet just like Harrison
wells had secret plans for Barry Allen
and a lot of you were a little weirded
out by Superman's appearance in episode
3 like it's like how come he can be on
screen but he can't speak they're like
they're really weird rules that Warner
Brothers has about what he can and can't
do on TV I'm totally fine with the way
they used him the only weird thing was
the actual like texting back and forth
I'm cool if he can only like email her
or send her messages like he can't speak
with his voice on screen because they
don't want to cast an actor for it but
that message this is never gonna happen
again
just let you know that he's not gonna be
saving her ass all the time so yeah he's
definitely gonna come back on the show
at some point you know maybe midseason
finale or before the actual season
finale next year but I think they're
gonna try and save it for really really
big stories would it be crazy if Maxwell
Lord my controlled Superman at some
point and Cara had to take him down I
can't imagine how they do that on screen
but that in my mind would be like the
most badass use of Superman that's it
you another good question for you guys
what do you want the show to do with
Superman assuming that they can only use
them in very limited ways and actually
just to talk about big arrow flash
crossover stuff there were some things
that happened in this week's episodes
that made me think about the New Gods
I feel like they'd actually be a really
good point of crossover for Supergirl
with arrow in the flash and I'm not even
talking about Darkseid I'm just thinking
you know things from New Genesis things
from Apocalypse parademons loose in the
multiverse assemble the Justice League
to kick some ass so what's gonna happen
next this is I have a flash trailer
video that I'm gonna do I'll do a Q&A in
that too in the reverse flash ring
giveaway that'll probably post Saturday
night after Doctor Who there is some new
Star Wars BTS that'll be posting later
tonight so lots of cool stuff happening
this weekend just in case you guys
haven't seen it I posted new Star Wars
footage last night you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for
all my other DC videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you